[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir cette manifestation sous
haute tension à Goma dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo
plusieurs milliers de personnes en
colère ont défilé contre le Rwanda qui
Galli est accusé par Kinshasa de
soutenir les rebelles du M23 qui ont
gagné du terrain ces derniers jours dans
l'est du pays reportage de nos
correspondants dans ce journal
le tout premier verdict de la Cour
Pénale spéciale pour les atrocités
commises en Centrafrique trois membres
d'un groupe armé ont été condamnés à des
peines allant de 20 ans de prison à la
perpétuité nous écouterons l'avocat des
partis civils dans un instant et à la
fin de ce journal je vous emmène au
Niger à la découverte d'un système
d'irrigation révolutionnaire son
inventeur un chercheur nigérien souhaite
le promouvoir auprès des agriculteurs ce
système permet une grande économie d'eau
dans un pays qui en manque cruellement
reportage à suivre
la colère a envahi les rues de Goma
chef-lieu de la province du Nord qui
vous en République démocratique du Congo
alors que les tensions sont vives entre
Kigali et Kinshasa des milliers de
manifestants défilés dans la ville
certains à moto étaient armés de bâton
et de Pierre des manifestants qui
protestaient contre le Rwanda accusé par
la RDC d'armée la milice du M23
reportage à Goma et à Kinshasa de Justin
kabomba et Aurélie Basara qui bangoula
[Applaudissements]
Deschamps pour crier leur colère contre
le Rwanda accusé d'être derrière les
rebelles du M23 ces centaines de
manifestants sont descendus dans les
rues de Goma pour montrer leur soutien
aux forces armées congolaises et surtout
pointer du doigt le pays voisin
[Musique]
par le Rwanda cette colère éclate alors
que le M23 gagne du terrain dans l'est
du pays la semaine dernière le groupe
armé a pris le contrôle de Kiwanja et
roue churros centre de localité située
sur la route stratégique Nationale 2 qui
desserve Goma dans le cortège ces jeunes
se disent prêts à combattre aux côtés
des forces congolaises pour stopper
l'avancée du M23 nous demandons à notre
gouvernement de nous donner des armes
pour combattre et s'il n'en est pas
capable alors nous allons nous battre
car nous avons la force nous préférons
mourir pour notre pays plutôt que de
nous entretuer à plus de 2000 km là
aussi l'indignation contre Kigali est
grande à Kinshasa beaucoup de Congolais
ne croient plus à la voix diplomatique
pour instaurer la paix la société civile
réclame une rupture totale des relations
avec le Rwanda on ne peut pas rester en
relation diplomatique avec un pays qui
vous agresse avec un pays qui ne fait
pas de la paix avec un pays qui profite
de vos ressources
pour
mettre en péril votre territoriale le
gouvernement congolais a demandé à
l'ambassadeur rwandais de quitter le
territoire dans un délai de 48 heures
l'Union européenne et les États-Unis ont
multiplié les contacts avec Kinshasa et
Kigali pour tenter une fois de plus de
trouver une voie pacifique au conflit
malgré les accusations de la RDC les
autorités rwandaises continuent de nier
tout soutien en gros armé du M23
la Guinée équatoriale a annoncé ce lundi
fermé ses frontières terrestres avec le
Cameroun et le Gabon pour éviter je cite
l'infiltration de groupe pouvant
déstabiliser la campagne présidentielle
elle débutera le 3 novembre aucune date
de réouverture n'a été donnée seule les
aéroports resteront ouverts pour rappel
le scrutin qui devait se tenir en avril
2023 a été avancé au 20 novembre par
décret un scrutin présidentiel en même
temps que les législatives les
sénatoriales et les municipales
on en vient à ce verdict s'il s'agit du
tout premier de la Cour Pénale spéciale
chargée d'enquêter sur les atrocités
commises en Centrafrique pendant la
guerre civile qui dure depuis 9 ans
trois membres d'un groupe armé ont été
condamnés à des peines allant de 20 ans
de prison à la perpétuité pour entre
autres crimes contre l'humanité et
crimes de guerre écoutez l'avocat des
participants
également la Cour Pénale spéciale plus
continuer à traquer également certains
groupes poissons que je dis toujours il
y a d'autres qui demeurent il y a
d'autres encore qui sont dans la ville
il faudrait qu'on leur mette la main
dessus mais félicitations cette cour par
rapport à cette décision et de toutes
les orientations de la société civile
que je coordonne sur la coalition des
orana sur la société sur la Cour Pénale
spéciale nous félicitons cette décision
et puis les réquisitoires dans l'affaire
de County Camara l'ex commandant en
rebelle libérien arrêté en France et
jugé par la Cour d'assise de Paris pour
des exactions commises pendant la guerre
civile l'accusation a requis la prison à
vie la défense appelée des quant à elle
pour l'acquittement face à l'absence de
preuves County Camara et poursuivi pour
acte de torture et de barbarie et
complicité de crimes contre l'humanité
le verdict sera rendu ce mercredi
on part au Ghana ou le président nana
kufo ado a cherché à rassurer son pays
en proie à une grave crise économique il
a tenté de convaincre que le
gouvernement pouvait répondre aux
difficultés notamment grâce à un
possible accord de prêt très très
controversé avec le FMI écouter le
oui
nous sommes en crise de non exact et je
n'exagère pas quand je dis cela
de considérer la décision d'aller vers
le Fond Monétaire International dans
cette optique
nous nous sommes adressés au fond pour
assainir à court terme nos finances
publiques et rétablir notre balance des
paiements tandis que nous continuons à
travailler sur les changements
structurels à moyen et long terme qui
sont au cœur de notre objectif pour
construire une économie ganéenne
résiliente
je sais que ça exerce une pression
intolérable sur les familles et les
entreprises je sais que les gens sont
poussés à faire des choix qu'ils ne
devraient pas avoir à faire et je sais
que ça a conduit à la dévaluation du
capital des commerçants et de vos
économies douloureusement accumulées
nous devons réduire notre dépendance à
l'égard des marchandises importées et
renforcer notre autonomie comme l'exige
notre objectif primordial de créer un
Ghana sans aide financière
au Niger un chercheur a mis au point un
système d'arrosage qui permet une très
grande économie d'eau à abdulmane Kahn
se bat désormais pour promouvoir sa
technologie auprès des agriculteurs
notre correspondant à Niamey à rôle
Girard s'est rendu dans la ferme
digitale du chercheur reportage
à première vue c'est une ferme comme les
autres avec des champs de culture des
moutons et des vaches seulement ici
l'expérience en cours pourrait changer
la donne au niveau national le système
d'arrosage est activé grâce à un simple
appel téléphonique et il fait en sorte
que les plantes ne manquent pas d'eau à
la goutte près en fonction de leurs
besoins
comme vous le savez qui dit technologie
dit un peu de coup et donc du coup les
producteurs qui est important moins il
n'a que son foncier comme capital et ne
peut pas le monnayer pour acheter et des
systèmes d'élégation mais par contre si
on l'amène un petit capital financier
ils peuvent acquérir cette technologie
facilement un système effectivement
onéreux pour un agriculteur nigérien
moyen puisque l'installation coûte
environ 500 euros alors que les revenus
des agriculteurs leur permettent
généralement uniquement de nourrir leurs
familles cet appareil récupère les
données météo et aussi celle de l'état
de déshydratation de la parcelle le tout
peut être géré à distance et ici c'est
toute la connectique qui permet
d'échanger entre la plante le fermier et
le sol ça c'est d'abord notre station de
base ici qui permet de prendre les
données et les transformer c'est juste
un relais qui transva ça au niveau de
notre base de données un arrosage
automatique et précis qui permet
également de réduire la pénibilité et au
travail des cultivateurs une partie des
tâches et dès leur supprimer
pierre
avant on arrosé avec les mains
maintenant l'eau coule dès qu'on
l'enclenche avec le téléphone donc on
peut aller faire d'autres tâches pendant
ce temps avant on perdait du temps à
aller chercher l'eau
selon les autorités c'est environ 100000
hectares de terrarables qui sont perdus
au Niger chaque année à cause de la
sécheresse mais pour beaucoup de
défenseurs d'initiatives de ce type
l'État nigérien montre peu d'intérêt
pour ces solutions compliquées à mettre
en place dans un contexte d'urgence
alimentaire
[Musique]
en Tunisie les vendants vendanges
s'annoncent bonne cette année les
professionnels du secteur aimeraient
encourager l'État à libéraliser le
secteur du vin et améliorer sa qualité
le vin tunisien séduit de plus en plus
aussi bien les locaux que les touristes
reportage de l'ilia Blaze et hamdicli
un groupe
la récolte du cépage Carignan est déjà
presque fini et promet un bon cru
excellent on est au moins à 12 12 degrés
12 et demi Mohamed benchir travaille
depuis deux décennies sur ce domaine de
200 hectares de vignes la quantité n'est
pas abondante mais la qualité y est une
baisse de production liée au manque
d'eau mais aussi un problème
d'importation de plan de raisin limité
par un quota à cause de la crainte d'une
bactérie la Xyl et la fastidosa le
secteur manque d'organisation et d'un
office pour le représenter la qualité
son ressent seul 30% des vins sont
d'appellation d'origine contrôlée comme
ceux de néféris donc il faudrait qu'on
reprenne tout ça petit à petit et vous
allez voir que le secteur par lui-même
il va s'améliorer et les vins en Tunisie
certainement vont s'améliorer la cave du
domaine néphéris produit ainsi de
nouveaux vins et diversifie son offre
avec des goûts plus fruités et un
étiquetage attractif pour une clientèle
de plus en plus présente sur le marché
les femmes avec l'ouverture de plusieurs
restaurants comme les Landes donc il y a
beaucoup de clientèles des mini donc on
a su adapter nos vins aussi à cette
clientèle mais la consommation d'alcool
reste tabou dans le pays à cause du
conservatisme religieux le développement
du secteur est un signe souvent négligé
par les autorités malgré son atout
économique on a pas mal de domaines
viticoles qui appartiennent à l'État et
qui sont en partie à l'abondance si
c'est pas totalement et je trouve que
c'est dommage de laisser ça comme ça en
friche ne pas les exploiter d'autant
plus qu'il y a des besoins les
professionnels ils voient ainsi une
opportunité pour la jeunesse qui souffre
du chômage mais aussi pour pouvoir
exporter du vin tunisien en augmentant
le rendement
la 11e édition de la folie de mode au
Burkina Faso plusieurs stylistes et
créateurs venus du Bénin du Sénégal de
la Côte d'Ivoire était présent à
Ouagadougou pour l'événement dans le
contexte d'insécurité que connaît le
pays la mode et bien plus qu'un art
c'est aussi un moyen de résister contre
les groupes armées on écoute
l'organisateur et le créateur Sébastien
Bazemo c'est aujourd'hui on a révélé le
défi en montrant que le Burkina était
debout debout par rapport à tout ce
qu'on traverse toute cette histoire de
terroriste djihadiste et où tout ça et
on a vu d'oublier cette histoire c'est
c'est cauchemar qu'on vit et on a envie
de revenir à nos réalités qui sont vive
la mode vivre dans le rêve vivre dans la
vie de tous les jours
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique restez avec nous l'info
continue sur France 24
[Musique]
et conditions de travail ont causé la
mort de plusieurs milliers de
travailleurs migrants
à la veille de la Coupe du monde de
football qui se tient au Qatar nos
journalistes se sont intéressés au sort
des milliers de travailleurs migrants
exploités voici la réalité dans laquelle
certains se retrouvent piégés cathares
les travailleurs de l'ombre avoir sur
France 24 et France 24